самохідна гаубиця м109l одна з переданих
Україні Італії працює у Донецькій
області
22-річний артилерист із позивним Шпак
розповідає цілять по піхоті й артилерії
противника
це
щільність роботи ми працюємо Практично
кожен день
підтримуємо нашу піхоту і це вимотує на
Донеччині і Запоріжжі ЗСУ поступово
рухаються вперед є просування на
таврійському напрямку а також на південь
від бахмута на думку екс-директора ЦРУ
Девіда петреуса успіхи стали можливими
завдяки тому що ЗСУ змінили тактику
голосування було неможливим через
глибину мінних полів відсутність
переваги в повітрі і брак броньованої
штурмової техніки яку скажімо США
використали по такі ситуації українці
застосовують малі групи піхоти по 10
людей які рухаються від посадки до
посадки промацуючи шлях через змінні
поля шукаючи шляхи обходу захищаючи
зайняті позиції і займаючи наступну
посадку наступний будинок
удари по російському флоту такі ураження
корабля і підводного човна у Севастополі
в ніч на 13 вересня теж вважаються
наступальними діями командувач
повітряних сил ЗСУ натякнув на роботу
української авіації з допомогою західних
далекобійних ракет шторм Shadow якщо США
нададуть Україні і свої далекобійні
ракети атакамс таких ударів може бути
більше на думку американських посадовців
атакам зможуть стати вирішальними для
контрнаступу надані США касетні
боєприпаси також сприяли просуванню ЗСУ
зокрема в районі роботиного такі снаряди
розкидають малі бомби і вражають живу
силу і техніку противника на відкритій
місцевості за повідомленнями ЗМІ США
можуть надіслати Україні ракети ще
більшої дальності з касетними бомбами у
нас також є касетні боєприпаси які
можуть застосовуватися система нехаймерс
які долітатимуть значно далі варто було
б надавати і їх теж адже вони мають
змогу вражати російські війська значно
далі від лінії фронту вони ефективні і
їх варто використовувати водночас
західні аналітики прогнозують з кінця
жовтня погода почне погіршуватися тож
наступальні операції сповільняться і в
Україні і на заході стримані в оцінках
того що ЗСУ зможуть досягти за цей час
перед українськими військовими стоїть
дуже складне завдання складніше за
будь-що що я міг би згадати з часів
Другої Світової війни
і набагато складніше ніж у двох війнах в
яких я мав честь бути командувачем
думаю українці чудово справляються є
підстави очікувати що вони зможуть
продовжувати повільний але невпинний
прогрес розширюючи прорив особливо
довкола роботиного просуваючись через
другої третьої лінії російської оборони
на думку очільника ГУР Кирила буданова
молодий бездоріжжя не вплинуть на
Контрнаступ адже головну роль на полі
бою грає не важка бронетехніка велика
насиченість протитанкову переносними
протитанковими комплексами іншими
одноразовими особливо протитанковими
засобами та дронами Камікадзе воно дуже
сильно знизила ефективність застосування
взагалі будь-якої бронетанкової техніки
тому більшістю на жаль наш наступ те що
називається йде на ногах
президент Зеленський в інтерв'ю CNN
заявив що після 4 місяців важкого
наступу деяка обіцяна заходом зброя усе
ще в дорозі з огляду на це експерти
вважають нинішнє просування ЗСУ значним
успіхом але все частіше мова йде про те
що наступний ривок доведеться робити
навесні
Я вважаю що цесу не зможуть досягти
Азовського моря цього року очевидно що
війна триватиме черговий український
наступ скоріш за все почнеться навесні
наступного року коли вже будуть f-16 це
буде великою перевагою адже одним з
найбільш слабких місць України є
відсутність будь-якої переваги
будь-якого захисту повітря для
механізованих бригад які перебувають на
фронтік
України будуть f-16 танки М1 Абрамс
землі поставку озброєнь протягом зими
краще було б прорватися зараз і
позбавити Росію можливості підтримувати
логістику і поставки які можуть тривати
взимку Якщо це не вдасться зробити Цієї
осені Хоча я думаю що може вдатися то
українські військові досягнуть цього
Наступної весни і в них буде більше
зброї за допомогою якої можна зробити
прорив з околиць бахмута де більше року
тривають бої евакуюють поранених з
червня українські військові звільнили 49
квадратних кілометрів у цьому регіоні
кожен метр має свою ціну зараз
відбувається штурм і ми все сделали на
отлично це добре
Ну трошки в нас ранених Ну нічого без
цього ніяк за словами експертів через
специфічний клімат на сході України до
ще й морози не будуть перепонують для
наступальних дій Росія активізувала свій
наступ на Бахмут саме в грудні торік
нині ініціатива в руках ЗСУ